hello fellow Guardians with a little
under a week left before the rise of
iron we thought would give you some tips
on how to prepare for Destiny's new DLC
first up save all of your exotic and
legendary ingram the hope is that the
Ingram's will decrypt to light levels
close to yours as they did with the
April update also hopefully you'll be
able to get new exotics but we'll have
to see it's probably best to wait until
your higher level to decrypt the ingram
so that you gain the maximum benefit
from them best places of farm exotic
Ingram's includes the challenge of
elders the Kings fall raid heroic strike
and the crucible remember to pop those
three of coins before fighting an ultra
or participating in the crucible
otherwise you can just stockpile three
of coins for the expansion itself
another tip is edging your faction
reputation to do this get your factions
to the point where they are about to
level on top of just edging your
factions you'll probably want to
stockpile heavy ammo synthesis motes of
light and other resources you could use
the level of your faction packages
should give you the chance to upgrade
your life remember packages in the rise
of iron will now give you the ability to
choose between a weapon or an armor
piece this will be a good chance to
upgrade your life factions that will net
you these item include the future war
cult dead orbit new monarchy the
Vanguard the crucible the gunsmith heirs
mourn as well as the Queen's wrath in
the house of judgment in the reef
remember max out your legendary marks if
you're lucky enough to have saved your
trials of Osiris quests you'll have easy
access to 50 marks you can also level up
and save as many pre-existing
legendaries you got from year to this
way when you dismantle them they'll
dismantle 45 legendary marks also if
you're already capped on legendary marks
you can start spending those on flying
planetary materials this way you'll have
the ability to upgrade your knee armor
and weapons come rise of iron assuming
you're an active player is quite easy to
replenish your marks I tend to buy about
40 to 60 materials at a time which is
about 30 marks another solid tip is to
save up some completed high experience
quests you can get a leg up on upgrading
your items and reputations by having
some of these quests already completed
one I highly recommend if you have it is
to finish shacks weekly quest the true
meaning of war you would need to have
finished the mountaintop quest line to
get this though the quest reward should
give you a good light level reward when
you decide to turn it in again it's
probably best to wait till the end of
the week as you'll be higher level
before
where you turn this in chances are you
won't be PvP in the first week
especially if you're getting ready for
the raid so having this quest done
already is very valuable other things to
start hoarding up include weapon parts
armor materials exotic chards motes of
light and strange coins you might as
well do some housecleaning while you're
at it clearly you can tell I have a
hoarding problem you should probably
start getting rid of some of your older
items or items you no longer use to
clear out space in your vault for the
rise of iron for those trying to get up
to speed light level wise my best advice
is to do heroic strikes the night ball
challenge of elders and the Kings fall
rate if possible use bungees fireteam
finder through the website or use
community sites like Reddit and destiny
lfg calm or net of course all these tips
are diminish or the coming release of
rise of iron the most important thing to
remember is to have fun if you're
feeling burnt out it might just be time
to take a break before the actual
release and enjoy it day one stay tuned
guardians to gamespot for more coverage
of Destiny's nukes expansion rise of
iron
Lori is good
excellent teamwork